Houston I understand you attended law School I did okay and when you came to Los Angeles?
Was your Focus to become an Attorney No it Actually wasn't that was the the main Reason I came to la
Is so i wouldn't become an Attorney and I went to law School in Virginia and
At a great law School and I really loved the Experience and did Really well
My Focus was on entertainment law and Litigation at
The Same University Where I went to law school there was a film School as?
Well and so Naturally given the the subject Matter of my study which, was Film law and Entertainment law I
Became friends with A number of Film Students at the Same University
Started Writing and Producing Content on the Side of law School and all the Spare Time you have in law School and
Then Just Kind of got bit by the Bug and Really
Started To drill Down in That Last semester of law School
You know, what Exactly do I want to do with the rest of my life is it you know. Cuz I'm very much A
you Know
I want to I want to pursue Work that doesn't Feel like Work and
If I could you know Money was no Option I could do Anything I wanted to do Would it be
Going Into The law Office Every day
It's gonna Be in Going to a courtroom every Day and
It wasn't that I was More attractive to the other Side of the Transaction on the Entertainment Side of things so?
Luckily the the Juris Doctor, degree
Is very Versatile and so I knew I could use it to
Pursue Entertainment as a producer as an agent as Whatever I wanted to do when I got out Here and
You know at least that's what i told my mother-In-law so as Though it wasn't a big waste of Time
But but yeah so so Once I graduated law School in Virginia
Pursued A, couple Opportunities There but, We really Made the decision to to really move out here, so we ten Years ago?
Just Packed up our Jetta Sold everything we Had and Just Came out here so and been Here ever Since has Been Great